[Musik]
[Gelächter]
111 von new york nach genf
kapitän muss zimmermann und seine crew
wünschen sich in einem anrichten
nur mit
einer warteliste kommt oder
man konnte gar nicht sich überlegen was
sagt falsch oder oder schief gehen
sollte
wir hatten alles was man sich wünschen
kann wir waren rundum glücklich
[Musik]
geschlossen
nehmen
[Musik]
es ist der tag in die geschichte
eingehen wird aus der schlimmste für die
swiss
[Musik]
der russischen offene
liebenswürdige menschen
und was ihn auszeichnet hätte ist ein
hervorragender pilot umso mehr hätte
hinterfragen
warum das so sei es auch beherrscht also
bis muss passieren
ich habe mich so was
ist
ich weiß von nichts am 6
wir sind mit ihm
hätte gauck next week
google-account jetzt zeige ich mir
gesagt sie wollten
ich war sekretärin und übersetzerin bei
der amerikanischen firma chris kraft da
hat er mich engagiert
und da hat es dann nach einer weile
gefunkt
wir lernten uns besser können hat und
zwischen uns wuchs die gegenseitige
zuneigung es aus der zuneigung liebe
würde
dies bis heute geblieben
[Gelächter]
kann es dafür nicht
donnerstag
wollte das nicht schon am mittwoch da
sein
sie will so lange wie möglich bei ihrem
freund bleiben
campbell
everyday
warum jetzt
was in genf führten wir ein schönes
leben wir waren glücklich die verdiente
gut und wir lebten in einem äußerst
angenehmen klima
wir hatten eine eng verbundene familie
geschaffen
all die schönen dinge im leben die wir
hatten nahmen wir für selbstverständlich
wir hatten ein außergewöhnlich
glückliches leben
von speed ja so schön
wo sie mir aus gesehen wir nicht
sozialer machen
dass ich das letzte
springen der
innenseite
passant ränder
georgia sehr temperamentvoll xxi in
beiden orten schien dies kann aus dem
fitnessclub eigentlich und zu erzählen
dass miro ist dann in new york getroffen
und wir sind sogar
gegangen wo ist gerrit an dieser misere
boxee ist ja nur ein 28
und sind dann
alles zusammen gemacht
service letztlich
bei
meininger gehabt führte dass ich er
trank sie satt york wo sie war kein kind
hat keiner fliegens ist schon mal
gesehen und dann hat es aber reicht das
geld das sie entdeckten im garten aus
wie sie der früh genau geortet hat
und irgendwann im westen sagen was es
bringt nicht muss der mieter gar nichts
fürs oder sich vorstellen bei frag sie
dass sie
so etwas soll wieder frage will ich bin
überzeugt dass sie das wirklich gemacht
[Musik]
zwischen schönheit von roxy ist ja keine
models
mit uniformen und so haben sie natürlich
irgendwie aus quellen dann zum mitmachen
mit einer jubiläums flügen
jubiläumsflug vom erstflug nach new york
ec4u zwar gemacht und der flug noch mal
gemacht
mit zwischenlandung was damals brauchte
und in der original uniform ja das hat
die forscherin tragisch zusammenhang und
ich das gefühl so hat sie eigentlich der
erste flug auf mallorca machen und
direkt daneben auch von aloxi
die restaurierte de c4 steht bereit
zusammen mit der vierköpfigen crew
staaten rund 30 personen in genf zu
diesem modernen flug abenteuer
[Musik]
nach über 5000 kilometern insgesamt rund
24 stunden flugdauer geht die rüstige
alte tante so zu boten wieder ganze flug
verlaufen ist sanft und weich
was mit pflegen damals spaß gemacht
haben
[Musik]
was ist so machen
deswegen stefanie
ich habe mir extra freigenommen sie
abzuholen du kannst ja auch am
donnerstag abholen vielleicht hatte ich
ablehne was für kleine und stefanie ich
wollte etwas unternehme dir vielleicht
aber du hattest keine pläne aber was
wenn doch hattest du nicht
fotografieren aber
leider
hast es zu spielen tennis
wir können dir auch gespräche
[Musik]
stefanies geritten mit leidenschaft
geritten sie war zweitbester der genfer
junior reiterinnen
ja
und
vorher hat sie wie ihr großer bruder
oliver geschwommen in einem schwimm club
es war immer schön die fanden das ganz
toll
[Musik]
mit dem flugzeug wonach er sagt das
ereignis habe ich weniger tag natürlich
new york geflogen ist im ganzen normalen
flug sieben überhaupt nie festgestellt
aber er sagt im nachhinein auf lag
es ist aussage sind es sie dass der
flügel ist absolut normal verhalten wie
immer bis anhin
ich bin sehr stolz
dass ich ab panasonic sie
sich sehr die firma xing weltweit
bekannt großes aufsehen das ist einmalig
sie und alt begeisterte firma das habe
ich mir aber anders
[Musik]
[Applaus]
im moment und fitness kann ja gute klima
ist dann ja auch noch ein nagelstudio
handelsgeschäft material das dann im
gestocher wieder da sind
urs
auch immer
der woche die
unfreiwillig zu werden
wir sehen ja immer zwei flüge auf das
new york gegangen als eine über kampf
und da wieder über kampf zurück unter
dir aktiv logik sie auf einen direktflug
und kann in pompeji ist auf dem kamper
flugplan xii das umgekippt
jetzt will ich für monique räten und
nicht für johnny also eigentlich muss
man einfach glück haben dass das man
über nacht artistik
[Musik]
kennedy
sie hatte ihren freund ein kanadier der
aber auch in genf groß geworden war und
studiert hatte der hatte einen lehrgang
in new york zu absolvieren für seine
bank und
da wollte sie ihn besuchen einfach nur
ein paar tage so eine knappe woche
und ursprünglich war sie gebucht auf den
rückflug über zürich
da hatte tatsächlich eine abgesagt ganz
kurzfristig hängt
sie konnte dann auf diesen flug und war
ganz happy
da
[Musik]
ich hatte ziemlich kennt vom militär
hierzu präsentiert plus 15
während die tories als zentrale schulter
an schulter fans gemacht und meine
schöne stiegen aber card sein
interessant
sind die leute sind in meinen augen
absolut spitze rück sich
die hand neues problem klar das sind
hervorragende pilot xii
wir haben aus der zeitung erfahren dass
der tennisspieler mark rossi auf diesen
flug gebucht war
aber er
irgendwas dazwischen gekommen ist wir
wissen nicht genau was und wir nehmen an
dass das der platz ist den stéphanie
dann eingenommen hat
sie 40
stress im letzten moment doch noch den
flug bekommen
machte zu informieren na ja meine eltern
bitte
ich konnte nach nur stefanie ich wollte
schon sehnsüchtig auf dich die dinge
funktionieren nicht
um stéphanie zu beschreiben da gibt es
nur ein wort hp glücklich sie war ein
glücklicher mensch sie war immer guter
laune in
all unseren erinnerungen sehen wir eine
lachende stefanie die auch uns zum
lachen brachte
darum drehte sich ihr ganzes leben
sie war eine äußerst begabte attraktive
die junge frau
kapitäns zimmermann first officer stefan
löw und seine crew wünschen ihnen einen
angenehmen flug
grandel kreiert haben hero ist ein
platz reserviert kommt mein partner ist
metro und spanisch versetzt worden
oktober fällig dann haben wir zwei mal
gespielt
und es ist die erste frau die wirklich
jedes mal grantig also sie hat viele
sehr drive kann und das hat mir sehr
imponiert
abstellen dass ich natürlich serie a
ziehen die persönlichkeit
und so haben wir dann so nach und nach
aber es hilft dass das große treffen der
gemeinde anders gegangen und ich teile
aus der schweiz
entweder wir setzen oder mehrere jobs
kosten aber ich halte das nicht mehr
laufen und dann hat sie sich weiter und
ist dann ist er zurück
wenn ich sie sehr günstige jahr misst
beschrieben denn ohne falsche
bescheidenheit muss ich sagen das ist
die leading airline sie andere airlines
sind kultur gewisse das macht 50 watt is
building operation also das ist
einzigartig sie ja das ist die maxime
dass wir jetzt wirklich sagen wir sind
wie eine große familie xxi das ist
verständlich sie eine extra meile sogar
in der not will natürlich meine
schnellen brüter auswärts für grün-rot
der steckbrief haben wir müssen
improvisieren aber genau die situation
eine andere person des spannend gefunden
wenn wir sind dran sich redet
sehr turbulent zu honig und sieht
einerseits als dann schlussendlich
schwieriger gemacht jetzt für mich weil
ich natürlich immer das gefühl kann ja
viele
einem anbieter oder aber es ist dann
schon hart wenn man alles das was man
natürlich etwas angenehmer sein
ich bisher jahren medikamente 11 er hat
sehr wenig es ist sehr zuverlässig
funktioniert sie es ist so eine
vorgängige dreimotorige typ sich und das
ist für sein noch immer beruhigend sie
das wenn
man das abstellen dass wir immer noch
mit 200 komfortables verfügt wie heute
die meisten flüge dass es spaß machen
[Musik]
eine andere
bisher ist sie und das ist nicht schwer
sondern auch schlanker wo mir gemacht
und 65 selektion
überblick über laufende weiterbildung
haben wir sehen höhere stand kopf
[Musik]
danke sowohl
es war ganz gut sie so ein typ
bowlingkugel abschlag
irgendwas oder
vielleicht doch was anderes sind
siebeneinhalb stunden
das inflight entertainment system wo im
dlv wurden ich ich es zeichen für die
swissair was führen die gesellschaft
nicht einfaches system kauft hätte
sondern es hat mir das beste sie damals
eigentlich der erste wo gestattet hat
dass jeder passagier also im platz in
die individuelle film nur das ist ein
resort sexy und das hätt zwangs ließ so
künstlich kinder kranken da sag ich
jetzt mal klärt dass es eine große hitze
die qualität und den haben wir deshalb
messen abstellen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
dass manches roten teppich
weil sich die frau auf dem fünfzigsten
und da wird es verkauft
letzte gruß mit einer führung
ja hoffentlich
es verkauft hat
gast aber keines mehr
jetzt das macht
dass bildung
der schmiede des fonds haben
in trance ist die wohl oder übel
begeistert
ja auch nicht
[Musik]
wenn sie zeit kostet
da sie nach ihren wünschen
[Musik]
die werkstatt
in dem sturz
die option mein konto
[Musik]
das mit dem cockpit rauch schmeckt und
zum glück praktischen hervor es hat
wirklich geht als normal erklärt bis
schmeckt und technischen sinne 1% oder
noma ev dvs der offene form von geld das
sie hoch jährigen die er vorbereitet um
vielleicht an gewartet hat dass das
essen schmeckt aber rauch im cockpit
praktischen hervor
[Musik]
ja
diskutiert wird
aber
ja ich mag es komisch
[Musik]
etliche conditions marc
ersten schritten im kurs button
[Musik]
mannschaft in der filmreihe mit
checkliste dass die standard verfahren
vor allem gleichgemacht der eine sitzt
ist das die einzige quer das ali punkt
ab kommt sind und was sehr wichtig ist
alle müsse vor was das nennt man hat
rauch und weiß nicht woher das kommt
um daraus neue erkenntnisse stehen vor
jedem triebwerk heiß
und wahrscheinlichkeit dass ihm ein
system das nur gut ist relativ groß
das sehen wir noch
es ist
[Musik]
was
completed
[Musik]
die panischen internationales zeichen wo
alle piloten und bodenstationen müssten
das problem die erste stufe vor wir sind
in einer schwierigen lage
und media ist stufe
jetzt hilft das mag in der cockpit
requests die meditative kombiniert
placer posten
des postens
boston sind sie gerade drüber geflogen
und posten keiner mag lange piste und
als blindflug system wo auch in der
nacht und bei schlechten weiteren
ausflug erwartet
[Musik]
wenn die muskulatur würde trainer jetzt
boston globe und zwischenstationen
mechanik recht wenn man aber die zieht
nämlich wenn das nicht geht um berichts
halifax der gruppen radikaler
ungeplanten zwischenlandung in halifax
in circa 20 bis 25 minuten kabine
vorbereiten bitte
[Musik]
sie müssten sich neue schnelle
taten perfekter technischer probleme
immer zwischenlanden das tut es sehr
leid dass ich mir sorgen machen sind
reine sicherheitsmaßnahme
aber ihr werdet wohl ziemlich verspätung
also nix mit überraschen
er wird zu überleben
was
wenn ich mal nicht wahr ist woher kommt
denn du nicht sehr stehe auch die wiehre
was nicht essentielle für den flug ab
aus der hilft der kabine das sind
treffen sind dritten auch krank machen
kann drauf ich mache mir auch nicht mehr
machen integra biene maja deaktiviert
aber zum trocknen
gott die lande
bewusster kommunikation mit der kabine
dass die kabine nicht vor auch vorhanden
ist
das ist nur ein cockpit
seine 20 uhr sollen der bezahlung 13
[Musik]
sie sind richtig halifax geflogen aber
sie sind nützlich sie und sie sind
netzwerk sie
mit einer großen flügel ist ja so dass
stark wicht bis verschwindet ohne
schwere risch wetters maximale
landegewicht die hantel wirklich
die fn die luft das most approbiert aber
sie haben dann müsse hilfe nicht es ist
10 vom flugplatz ski und wenn jetzt
schnell und häufig geht das einfach
nicht
naja
cockpit voice recorder
es ist unglaublich viel glück und wie
diszipliniert dass ich im cockpit grid
worden ist
es hat mir im versprach
sogar wo sie im merchant sie
deklarierten was notabene
die piloten
machten will es musste bis passiert sein
cockpit das sofort beten quarks ist
jetzt ist es ganz schlimm
muss sich vorstelle was offenbar
flugzeug passiert wenn das gesamte
elektrische systeme steht
ich habe mir vorstellen dass du daraus
in der kabine
sehr ruhig
im cockpit
kann sie einfach versucht der flügel in
der luft halten und kontrollieren
wissen der knapp aus dem schluss
passiert ist
[Musik]
so
ungefähr was die durch geflogen sind vom
rathmann kommunikation
kommunikation zwischen piloten wie
möglich offen ist
fünf minuten hinzog flogen
[Musik]
wieso
sprechen
[Musik]
es ist ein moment wo noch nie wird für
das telefonat blüte swissair maschine
vom radarschirm verschwunden
ein mini verbaut eigene mixe und bin
richtig luca vergangen in einem büro
innere 30 andreas krieg und alle
vorgeschaltet ganz ausgeschaltet und
gestattet
wer noch nicht wisst was ist genau
passiert also mehr rangnick ist ist das
new york city oder new york kennt man ja
im gleichzeitig ein flugzeug in der luft
ta
vorliegt
es ist das 111
[Musik]
ich habe eine kleine gabe
das einfach nicht glauben es nicht einen
faustischen das ist das was
im labor ist zweiter und ich
praktisch bekannt an bord
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die ersten mal im journal
am mikrofon ist daniel eisen die
swissair maschine des fluges new york es
ist eine ausgeglichene kanadas
abgestürzt dies ist das hauptthema der
sendung
vor wenigen stunden ist das flugzeug des
kurses neuer trend über den osten
kanadas abgestürzt die maschine vom typ
md 11 war am abend ortszeit in new york
gestartet und stürzte wenig später
arbeitslos
unter
www.schloss
der shop gestützt
das flugzeug verschwand in einer höhe
von zirka 350 metern um 22 uhr 30
ortszeit
geheimnisse passagier bedienen und so
tue als wärme passiert
mehr an der welle dass die passagiere
ausstiegen ohne dass ihr bis ich setze
zerstoßen erfahren
ich muss sagen ich befrage sich so nach
flugpassagieren schlafen die meisten und
audi fahren und
auf dem flug aus der hand gibt telefon
sind in port wurde in der kabine und das
ist meine geworden dass man dann von
2000 meter höhe hat keine hüte und
mir haben auch essbar
telefoniert hat
und hier zwei haben der fahrer dass der
100 meter abgestürzt ist
und der meister gab ihm erhebt ein g 20
suchen
und gemüse unter kontrolle bringen will
während im vorjahr kamen 220 panik an
bord das wäre
ich sollte sie am nächsten morgen am
genfer flughafen abholen wir freuen uns
wahnsinnig auf ihre heimkehr
wir hatten nicht mehr direkt mit ihr
gesprochen doch dann frühmorgens erhielt
google einen anruf aus new york
er fragte ob
wir etwas gehört hatten von stefanie und
da haben wir gesagt nein sie war ja
eigentlich gar nicht auf dem flug
und er sagte ja
machen sie mal den fernseher an
diese des kanadischen fernsehens
dutzende von schiffen der kanadischen
marine sind unterwegs sie werden
unterstützt von unzähligen fischerbooten
mit leuchtkörpern würde szenerie erhält
augenzeugen berichten von flugzeug
stücken und leichenteilen de mer
schwimmen das mehr ein riesiges
trümmerfeld
hören sie
war auf dem flug nach zürich oder nach
genf
ja
ja ja
stefanie schau
ach
nein
von gestern gestellt
heißester die wussten natürlich dass ich
dabei war sahen hier jetzt so aber sie
wollten noch nichts sagen weil sie waren
noch nie überhaupt nicht vorbereitet
was sie den familien jetzt sagen sollten
sie sind gekommen um ihre angehörigen
abzuholen aber sr 111 wird nicht lang
zuerst hieß es bloß rita de also
verspätet dann der schock flug sr 111
abgestürzt
immer wieder der blick auf den monitor
eine hilflose geste informationen gibt
es wenige und wenn dann nur schlechte
chrome sind in genf landete
mir der flug auf der direktor und
regierungspräsident vorgang feindes in
empfang sofort zum comet seinen turm und
da bin ich fast unschlagbar oder
außerdem 526 medien liefert ganzer wald
bisher größte etwas eigentlich passiert
ist ist sehr sehr lang gange und wir
haben die devise kann fließend immer
wieder informieren aber nur fakten
ich hab's im radio gehört ich kann nur
hoffen dass mein sohn nicht an bord ist
bis jetzt weiß ich nichts ich war
[Musik]
new york die massen auf der rutschbahn
das war eine dramatische stunden die wir
da warten mussten vom kreistag hast
das ist wird er bestimmt schon beim
einchecken wer in welchem flug saß uns
hat mir mal gesagt warten sie ab bis
der flieger von zürich gelandet ist und
dann sagen wir ihnen bescheid und morgen
um halb im juni tabak und sommer vom
flughafen terminal und hochhackige für
passagiere vom direktflug von neujahr
15-jährige erlösten die buchungsmaschine
knoke sie aber der informationsdienst
keine liebeshandlung kollegen
abrüstungsvertrag seitdem der clubszene
was er ja einen abstürzt
[Applaus]
wir noch das sagen und methodisch das
ist nicht zum ersten mal wirklich
bewusst wurde dass es das sind bruchteil
von sekunden
wo dann einfach entscheidet
ich bin ja herr schafft raum für die
sind ja nur knapp den angestammten flüge
sind jahrelang sie mir hat es ja noch
nachher hoch die sind comeback rolex sea
ich hatte hannelore kraft beim club sie
es
[Musik]
ich habe meine schwester müsste
eigentlich hier seien aber sicher bin
ich nicht das letzte minute umbuchen
musste
sowie der julie gerster verstärkt um so
größer trikot ihre schwester und ihr
auftaucht ist sieht er was mit der
anderen swissair maschine passiert ist
organischen riesiger stein vom herzen
dass wir uns vorher ist stoff der
unglücksflieger gemacht wo der welt
nicht genug von sich
mit
vergnügen ist dem 65 ich habe das ganz
gut begrüßt der mobilisierung
kapitulieren oder das furchtbarste
für ein unternehmen wie das unsere
für
führungsverantwortliche in unserem
unternehmen ist diese nacht geschehen
noch in der nacht wurden erste leichen
geborgen die sterblichen überreste der
passagiere wurden in eine provisorische
aufbahrungshalle gebracht dort sollen
sie identifiziert werden und die suche
dauert an
das telefon läutet und mit vorgesetzten
ich traf sie und hat mir das ganz ruhig
erzählt dass in der nacht das flugzeug
abgestürzt ist und das hätte etwas
surreal sky will wie sehr ich so sicher
und
qualitätsbewusst und sich sonst das ist
doch ne gar und also zu sich mercedes
ruhiges gespräch miteinander geführt und
eine mixed und du bist jetzt auf ein
erster flug schickt die
mittelgruppe verliert mit der gruppe
forschung ist schickt man sich über
wer die gegend kennt weiß sich also
setzte dramatik erhöhte sich so eine
schöne gegend ich so dramatisch schön
und müsse
organisieren dass man so nah wie möglich
an der stelle wo das flugzeug ist mehr
aber nicht
und mini ist ja wir was trifft man hätte
also schau quartal irgendwelche
flugzeugteile uhr
was erwarten was muss man nicht erwarten
[Musik]
nachdem die zimmer
bolte airforce base gange dass die
städte wurden häufig sagen die
untersuchung stattgefunden hat und sein
team eine herkules no search and rescue
of light google machen also der flug wo
man gesagt hat findet man über werden wo
ohne den glaspokal entkommen einfach
tief geflogen ist und was man sehen sind
bedrohlich sie sind einzelne setzte sich
sie und zuschnitt
[Musik]
ich wusste es bereits
ich hatte diese vorahnung dass sie tot
war
dann kam ein polizist und eine
vertreterin des wissens zu uns und
überbrachten uns die nachricht von ihrem
tod
war der anfang
[Musik]
will mio frank sie sind sind offenbar
mini daten an der mini telefon haben
oder dass irgendwas nicht gerade in
boxen ja und dann
nicht so schnell wie möglich darauf
schnecken welche informationen über
und zwar nicht kommen studenten bereits
freunde fotos vor die auf zwei fragen
die
zum mich empfangen mich nicht allein auf
die idealsituation
wasserwerks ist natürlich mein kind von
der schule sind und die einen sagen das
ist
das schlimmste nicht
was das ist
[Musik]
das trauma also bisher fort und
praktisch sie dass das einfach nicht
mehr an das wichtigste einnahme
vergessen familien auch weil ich nehme
den straßen im rennen wie sie heißen
[Musik]
ich bin vorher
gut funktioniert aber den romand ist
einfach im schnitt mit goya
mami
ami
seit über 30 stunden sind die retter vor
der küste von hd fox im einsatz fischen
bruchstücke des schlimmsten unglücke in
der geschichte der swissair aus dem meer
taschen des personals
teile des flugzeugs
habseligkeiten der passagiere
ein fund war besonders herz zu brechen
ein liebesbrief den jemand während des
flugs schrieb wir fanden ihn im wasser
und steckten ihn in eine plastikhülle
die küstenwache wird in der familie
übergeben
ganz viel telefon über hoch
freunde bekannte
bin dann völlig
überdreht sie natürlich höllisch laufen
aber bist ohne hilfe nicht schlafen und
ich bin einfach etappe gegangen habe
apotheker als problem erklärt
ich will jetzt gar und tabletten und
unbedingt hilfe in anspruch nehmen ich
muss ihm versprechen dass ich mein es
nicht gehen dass sich wirklich zum arzt
gehen wird morgen nach dem 11
konzernspitze wurde swissair formen
schwierigen auftritt ich möchte an
dieser stelle mein beileid an alle
betroffenen sei dass angehörige von
passagieren angehörige der
besatzungsmitglieder
ausdrücken wir alle sind schockiert
es ist das schlimmste des sangster in
der schweizer luftfahrt geschichte die
ganze schweiz traut mit die platten
stehen auf halbmast
im namen des bundesrates spreche ich den
angehörigen der opfer unser tiefstes
beileid aus wir werden morgen
10.00
einen flug für angehörige nach hacks
fliegen
am pos
geschichte die eltern paten und freunde
von den opfern die schweiz die reise
gegangen wo sie erhält macht 3 ist nach
kanada am unglücksort jedes wurden
angehörige wird war in der ganzen zeit
von einer betreuerin oder ein betreuer
begleitet
es ist noch nicht ganz aus holz mittag
wurde er brust die hunde zwar richtig
harry fox setup gruppe der kontrollturm
hierzu verabschiedet einen guten tag
noch swissair und auf wiedersehen
auch ich nahm diesen flug nach halifax
während gut zu hause blieb
in kanada wurden wir waren empfangen
also dass die menschen dort haben sich
liebevoll um uns gekümmert
ihre eigene erschütterung lösten mir
eine art zugehörigkeitsgefühl aus weil
sie alle so nett zu mir waren
das war das wichtigste element während
ihnen zwei tagen in halifax
der leuchtturm von peggy scope heute
früh für die angehörigen der opfer ist
er zum sinnbild für die katastrophe
geworden sie tragen ganz persönliche
erinnerungen mit sich
im laufe des tages die sonne hat den
nebel inzwischen verdrängt kommen mehr
als 300 frauen und männer sie haben
unterwegs blumen gepflückt sie halten
einander fest kauern auf dem kargen
boden oder schauen einfach aufs meer
hinaus
bis die wir können oft friedhof
repräsentiert mit seinen bewegungen ganz
viel zeremonien waren eher so ein
dramatisches ereignis kommt und
eigentlich nur dass pekings co vorstand
auf das meer aber das muss möglich sie
das ist nähe schaffen
nach starts aber verloren hat
man muss sich vorstellen die manche hin
bis zum diebstahl oder die ente sind
still die andere
versucht irgendwie
hast du alles unter kontrolle
also hätten verschiedene die hinter
wirklich ganz verschiedene situationen
erlebt in der luft wie zum beispiel
manche nuss und ein anderer kulturkreis
seiten wie wir in den aufnahmen event
empfehlung sehe wie iss familienmitglied
idee das flugzeug innen stecken ist und
zu stark zu ihrem tod nicht
hier in den schrank seite liegend nicht
bevor wir nicht sind körper hängt das
mit den körper nach nach
rehren und würdigen und ihre vorsätze
[Musik]
ursprünglich lag die die verstorbene
offenes werk präsentieren das die
angehörigen sich und visuell
identifizieren das ein sehr schnell
gemerkt dass es eine gott nicht die
einzige person haben wir als ganzen
körper so
erkenne an dass andere ist der stadt
zerstört sie könnte zu einer halle
kommen die säule für sammler die terra x
-reihe dem hotel untersetzung sogar so
eine bühne kam und der chef vor insekten
die
schwarze machen
derweil
novartis freund
[Musik]
mit diesem gesang schicken die indianer
von schottland ihre verstorbenen in die
nächste welt
wasser ist für sie heilig ein guter ort
der gedenkgottesdienst für die opfer der
verunglückten swissair maschine und
gleichzeitig danksagung an alle die bei
ihrer bergung mithelfen angereist auch
bundespräsident flavio cotti und kanadas
ministerpräsident john key
den familien der opfer kann ich nur
sagen dass sie im geist der immer bei
uns sind dass wir sie nie vergessen
werden sagt christa wolf vom kanadischen
volk ein blumenkranz aufs meer und ein
letzter kanonen salut
es blieb man immer noch im kopf der
empfang in halifax ich bin ja like sind
dann
stand da in militärischen ehren in
uniform und
empfangen
salutieren und das ist
ein wahnsinns griffen der bank sichern
tiefe betroffenheit aus die namen der
229 passagiere verlesen werden
franz war
maria
[Musik]
am selben tag bin ich sehr stimme auf
deckungskäufe
mallorca wo alle anderen
dann bin ich
bin auf die straße kunden
die zerbrochen
[Musik]
titan ist ausruhen und dann hat eine
hauptstadt kühle
und keine liebesbeziehung
[Musik]
seit sieben wochen machen sich jeden tag
hunderte von helfern per boot auf den
weg zur absturzstelle
vor dem fischerdorf disco
tonnen trauriger fracht werden jeden
abend bei halifax an land gebracht
spezialisten aus dem ganzen land werden
die menschlichen überreste in quellen
der kleinarbeit untersuchen und
katalogisieren der uferlandschaft
p500 armee-angehörige
zahnarzthelfer von der kroatischen armee
ungefähr 50 polizeibeamte in triesen
umfang sie natürlich alles perfekt
organisiert sie die leichenteile wurden
zu einem luftwaffenstützpunkt bei
halifax gebracht nach der inspektion
durch gerichtsmediziner in einem hangar
werden die menschlichen überreste in
riesigen kühlcontainern tiefgefroren
ziel ist dass man sämtliche opfer
identifiziert und das hätten erreicht
also mehr hält natürlich noch der
klassische und schnellste methode
versucht die ihr körper zu
identifizieren das ist ein sitz der
fingerabdruck das andere sehr effiziente
mittel ist die zahl herzliche
identifikation sie um den schließlich
den untersuchten sie
bist du
jetzt dfs
sie wollen wissen wann du wieder zurück
kommst
hallo ja
ja
hier sagt sie hier
nach dem unfall lagen erst mal die
nerven blank man wurde
unerträglich für den partner und war
alles fand man schrecklich was der
andere machte und gegenseitig es war ja
so dass das unheil das kam plötzlich
über nacht
sprichwörtlich und das hat und unsere
ganze lebensbasis auf den kopf gestellt
sie ist auch meiner tochter
[Musik]
die
sixty
[Musik]
schade
weiterhin treu
wir müssen uns immer bewusst sein dass
unser leben aus der vergangenheit und
der zukunft besteht
ist alles in einer schachtel verstaut
die nur die vergangenheit enthält
es gibt keine gegenwart und keine
zukunft beides existiert nicht
ich habe kürzlich gehört selbst der
gemahl der britischen königin der duke
of edinburgh einmal gesagt hat
wenn im leben etwas ganz schlimmes
passiert muss man anhalten sich das
geschehene vor augen halten und sich
eingestehen das ist wirklich passiert
ist
nur so kann man damit weiterleben
tut man das nicht er singt man man muss
damit weiterleben wenn etwas positives
daraus machen
[Musik]
das paar
credit suisse
[Applaus]
[Musik]
schön
die formel 1 bin glücklich
[Musik]
mir hat lang beschäftigt was der krug
sich warum der flüge aber kette spezial
lang lang ist also mehr hätten annika
und soweit ich mich erinnere ist das gar
nicht untersucht die
flugzeugunfall
mit
wirklichen geschichte
was passiert ist sie suchen zu sammeln
die trümmer einer md 11 in denen
verborgene spüren erzählen können warum
die maschine abgestürzt ist
die meisten dieser trümmerteile befinden
sich auf dem meeresgrund rund 60 meter
unter der oberfläche in den ersten tagen
werden hauptsächlich taucher für die
bergung eingesetzt ein schwieriger job
stück für stück wird 13 eingesammelt
denn untersucht werden kann nur was
wieder ans tageslicht gelangt
zusammen sechs
wochen fallen wie schnitt bis zum ring
macht
man macht es dann wenn die
rekonstruktion vor dem rock wenn das
bringt wo man sie findet jetzt dem fall
ist sie dass das funktioniert oder brand
hat und dabei ein schlauch gelöscht
worden ist wasser kritisch und das hat
ein auto so in den endzustand ge und der
hat natürlich bis zu blues zeit wie sich
das für entwickelt hat wenn es
entsprechend an zugkraft
manchmal arbeitest du hier zwei drei
tage ohne dass was passiert das kann
schon frustrierend sein an anderen tagen
vielleicht liegt's an den sternen passen
die teile sehr schön zusammen
wie es wieder eine möglichkeit
sieht so aus als wenn es einmal zusammen
war sehen sie das band hier stimmt über
ein mehr oder weniger ein kleines stück
das hier fehlt aber es scheint möglich
dass das zusammenpasst ich würde sagen
es passt
[Musik]
man muss doch sehen sind
22 menschen ums leben das hat sehr viel
leid ausgelöst und ich würde sagen
werden oder einen unfall verhindern dann
würde ich meine rache hat sich der
aufwand auf jeden fall
da hattest du das café schon entdeckt
nettes restaurant hast du dann gekauft
hast
du
denn da ist das war auf meiner zweiten
reise auch die war von swissair
organisiert worden
da war dieses gasthaus
ich sage das ist zum verkauf stand und
während ich dort war machte ich ein
kaufangebot
ok
[Applaus]
märz zur abstimmung
jetzt kickt
du bist dir vorstellen
hier
setzen die autos
hier kann das management
jetzt machen wir hier
frische fische
ist wie auch die auto heute hier wir
können hier auch
ich finde es gut dass etwas neues kommt
jetzt
ich war einfach froh dass er sich da
wieder gefunden hat für mich war
nordamerika überhaupt keine option
es ist auch heute noch nicht bin ich bin
europäerin leib und seele und
nordamerika ist ist nicht meine welt das
ist wirklich ein anderen andere kultur
und dann
gottverlassenen dorf so am rande von
kanada
was sollte ich da machen
für google wäre das kein leben gewesen
sie war unglaublich tolerant ist und wie
es mich gehen
könnte mir die freiheit dorthin zu gehen
[Musik]
anfang oktober
2001 die öffentlichkeit will eine
antwort auf die frage nach dem
ausgangspunkt des feuers 24 mögliche
varianten des katastrophen verlauf
stehen zur diskussion
aufgrund der auslegeordnung der
kabelbündel können die drähte ziemlich
genau dort positioniert werden wo sie
sich im flugzeug befunden hatten jetzt
ist die stelle einwandfrei bestimmt
wurde entscheidende funke den brand
ausgelöst haben muss
das passt
modell finden
da muss es sein innerhalb des cockpits
gleich vor der rückwand dieselbe stelle
im cockpit einer md 11 verborgen hinter
dem panel mit den sicherungen hinter
drähten kabeln und befestigungsteile
hier fügen sich die puzzleteile zusammen
an dieser uneinsehbaren stelle hat der
kurzschluss mit großer
wahrscheinlichkeit die isolation smarten
entzündet was mit wenig sich bewusst
wollte nicht vor dem unfall ist das eben
die isolation smarter zwar testet wurde
sind mit flamme mit offener flamme und
das material hat an die eigenschaft kann
also sicher so eine art wie zurück sogar
hat vor der flamme und dadurch auch
nicht richtig dass
ihr steckt im rahmen von deren
untersuchung das war mal stoppen offener
flamme ein funke hat dass der funk hat
eine benützung der sonne zurückziehen
oder zurück wie vor dem material geführt
hat sondern der klang zum dann
insbesondere
luminoso für die stanz materials
entzünden die alten swissair matten die
den bisherigen test bestanden hatten
werden im labor dem neuen verfahren
unterzogen
drei sekunden lang hätte das feuer
brennen dürfe nun nicht weiter als 5 cm
und die matte hat sieben minuten nach
der entzündung immer noch gebrannt
die unfalluntersuchung gehen davon aus
dass das bordunterhaltungssystem mit
großer wahrscheinlichkeit in die
auslösung des feuers involviert war und
damals das ist vielleicht da noch die
anders als hüter hand halt so sie stehen
schon ein weg der bildschirmschoner ganz
anders schließen hat sehr viel mehl ei
stieg konsumiert und sich wieder biss
nicht optimal hoffe dass es zu dem
brandausbruch trainer
es ist als ob sie das meer vor der
operation wie
techniker aus ihrer sicht
das system ist noch nicht optimal aus
griff
und entsprechender antrag gestellt aus
der schweiz entwickelte vom 7
die oberstufe
hat dann entschieden
unter druck von marketing dass das
system i punkt wird und in
sehr
großen ebit ist das ebit wurde meint
fremde marine hätte mit überhaupt
gemacht werde
ich meinte das ist suboptimal
[Musik]
red der pike auf
ich ging nicht dorthin um möglichst nah
bei stefanie zu sein ich ging dorthin
weil die umstände dieses fischerdorf ist
dieses gasthaus mit seinem laden auf
meinen weg gelegt hatten
es gab mir die möglichkeit mich von genf
abzuwenden und von all den dingen die in
meinen augen mein leben ausmachten
so konnte ich mit den wenigen
bruchstücken die mir geblieben waren
eine neue existenz aufbauen ist es in
der ich einen beitrag zum leben leisten
konnte
das ist schon bitter
insbesondere haus
er hat sich dann wirklich einen namen
gemacht als einen vorzüglichen humer ort
so gut hummer essen konnte
hast du noch genügend jobs zu bekommen
über all die jahre waren glaube ich acht
jahre
haben wir eigentlich immer telefonischen
kontakt gehabt
ich hab das gespürt dass ich dabei war
und es
ist zu wollen wird wir lernten
miteinander zu leben ohne zusammen zu
sein auch wenn wir auf zwei
verschiedenen kontinenten lebten blieb
während dieser ganzen zeit das
gegenseitige verständnis
[Musik]
ich konnte sie nicht verändern sie hat
ihre eigene persönlichkeit und zum teil
ganz andere meinungen als ich und ich
hatte meine persönlichkeit mit zum teil
ganz anderen meinungen als sie und ich
glaube das ist heute noch so
wir sind eigentlich
doch recht glücklich muss ich sagen
ja
alle flüge nach her bin ich nie mehr so
locker flockig
start und landung sind für mich immer
tanzen das spannungsmoment wurde wo mich
dann die sorglosigkeit es laufe für
flüge
stimmen auch wie mich das immer noch
erschüttert worden darüber muss sich
natürlich trotzdem
auseinandersetzungen oder auseinander
doch die vier bieter auf sie und und und
ich die gar nicht weg und so kann man so
philosophisch wird repariert gestartet
dann doch irgendwie doof nicht aber
nicht einmal ab dann will ich treffen
muss halt wieder irgendwo dass
das land sich einige gedanken
[Musik]
die besserung
da
zu sein
wünscht sich
[Musik]